tonight's starter christian javier one
who really impressed from the beginning
he's making his fourth start of the year
so far and then that last start against
the angels
struck out nine
trying to hold up he goes around says
tim timmons the home plate on fire lewis
strikes out to end the inning first
strikeout for christian javier mariners
failed to score in the first
marco gonzalez
going to take the mound this would be
his fifth start on the year one and two
with an eri just over six and 22 in the
third eight walks 19 strikeouts for
marco
[Applause]
first pitch seeger
snares that hot biscuit wow
that was smoked well in the hot corner
for a reason and kyle was playing in on
the cut of the grass the case take the
bun away
i almost caught that behind him
that's a mexilo on that
you see there from grantland
the blooper
tremell knows
very nice gold glove play casual
over-the-shoulder catch
pitch breaking ball swing and a miss and
what a curveball by
marco gonzalez
wow we got him one another great
curveball marco got the stroll working
tonight he's six up six down looking
good
fastball swinging strike murphy goes
down
that is strikeout number two for javier
went away here in the third
ground ball towards the hole correa to
altuve and the return throw in time for
the double play
tough turn by correa to altuve that is a
great turn to finish off this inning
carlos going to his right great feed and
how about the quick turn and throw from
jose altuve to finish off that inning
that was beautifully done bottom half of
the fourth inning marco gonzalez so far
has just faced one over the minimum he
walked miles straw in a 3-2 pitch last
inning and he will face a two three and
four hitters michael brantley alex
bregman and jordan alvarez
in the center field that'll be the first
hit of the night for the astros
michael brantley now with a six-game
hitting streak
clean single to center to lead off the
fourth
hopefully that gets the bats going for
the houston astros to seemer right down
the middle and right back up the box
goes michael brantley
alex rips one down the left field line
fair ball all the way to the wall
michael brandley heading to third he'll
be held up there alex bregman a double
astros in business second and third
nobody else
alex got a really good curveball to hit
right here and he actually stayed back
on this one nicely
that is just a curveball coming back to
the fat part of the plate all alex had
to do is wait you can see the hips open
up early
but the hand stayed back and then
followed the hips as he turned on that
one and hit a rocker in the left
and he shoots one to left field slicing
away and a nice diving play by sam
hagerty and left
in the score easily is michael brantley
on the sac fly by alvarez it's one
nothing astros
good batting by jordan got a curveball
up just kind of hanging out over the
plate just flips it into left field he
knew it was a sacrifice fly if not more
took a good play by hagerty out there to
chase that down and turn it into a sac
fly
yeah i'd love to see kyle tucker come up
big here's with some of the tough luck
he's hit into yeah he's due for a flare
or two to drop in is what you're saying
ground ball towards the middle diving
stop and everybody's safe nice call
plumber a little ground ball and a
perfect spot gives kyle tucker an rbi
infield hit
it's two to nothing astro
2-2 pitch
got him so 31 pitches
gives up a couple runs strands two it's
two-nothing asteroids
he is off and running and he puts it in
play but it's in the right field
kyle tucker will come on and make the
play hagerty a late return to first and
he's out
sam haggard he kept waiting for that
ball to maybe fall in by the time he
made his way back to first it was too
late terrible base running i agree worst
case scenario is there's an out at
second base and a runner on first but
instead
tucker was well underneath that ball too
it wasn't an extreme effort but did a
great job throwing on the run to make
sure he got haggerty on that play
there you go
broken over with the slider christian
javier picks up a strikeout to end the
fifth inning we are halfway home javier
and the astros cruising along leading
two to nothing
yuli guriel looking for his first hit
tonight julie to center field tramell
back still going back he's at the track
he looks up it's off the wall yuli
guriel will trot into second base with a
double off the center field wall with
two outs for the astros this one right
here trying to leave center field he got
a mistake up out over the plate and he
squared it up nicely because 103 103.2
miles an hour off the bat
tramell had to give up on it
about halfway up that wall
and he hits the ball hard to right field
coming on and making a sliding catch is
mitch haniger that's kind of how it's
gone for kyle all year long line drive
out to end the sixth inning two left on
base still two nothing christian javier
going back to the mound for the seventh
inning
line drive caught by alex fregman
lewis pulled one trying to get it over
the head of alex bregman but he makes
the play jumping for the catch for out
number one
swing and a miss christian javier
claps into the glove seven innings of
shutout baseball
first time he's gone this deep in his
career
hey then two nothing astros lead seattle
and brooks rayleigh first one out of the
bullpen for the astros
called third strike beautiful pitch by
brooks rayleigh to get the first out of
the inning
ball popped high in the air martin
maldonado fires the mask away now
drifting towards the stands puts it away
for out number two
that's getting it done
swaying and a miss speaking of getting
it done brooks rayleigh a three-pitch
strikeout of jp crawford and a one two
three eight
really very effective as we head to the
bottom half two nothing astros
freshly off to a good start this season
it's been a good home stand for him also
pouring four or five in safe situations
versus seattle since 2019 that era at
0.9
fly ball right field tucker back near
the track onto the track puts it away
for out number one
oh two pitch ground ball right side yuli
will flip it to presley covering and
that's out number two
stayed ahead of france that entire at
bat and got the dangerous second baseman
for the second out
crowd of
14403 on a tuesday night urging presley
to finish things off right
here swing and a miss martin maldonado
holds on the astros end up with a two
hit three pitcher combined shutout they
have now won
five in the first six games on this home
stand and plummer that was a nice win
with christian javier doing most of the
work